aumenta el rechazo contra la vacuna de
astrazéneca en europa alemania francia e
italia suspendieron la inoculación con
la solución de la firma anglo sueca el
país germano lo hizo tras la
recomendación del instituto por el ritz
encargado de la regulación de vacunas en
la decisión de hoy es una medida
puramente de precaución se han
administrado millones de vacunas con
extras génica en todo el mundo todos
somos muy conscientes de las
consecuencias de esta decisión y no la
tomamos a la ligera dejen greene unas
declaraciones muy distintas a las
pronunciadas el viernes en la mayor
economía de la unión europea lamentó que
según la información que tenemos algunos
países de la unión europea hayan
suspendido la vacunación con extra
escénica además de alemania italia y
francia- en europa también han
suspendido temporalmente la vacunación
países como dinamarca noruega países
bajos irlanda bulgaria e islandia unas
decisiones que contrastan con las
peticiones de la organización mundial de
la salud de no pausar campañas de
vacunación en esta línea se pronunció el
primer ministro de reino unido boris
johnson
y seguimos confiando mucho en el
programa de astrazéneca y es genial ver
que sí
a tal velocidad en todo reino unido- las
interrupciones en la inoculación
estarían causadas por presuntos
problemas de coagulación que habrían
llegado a ser fatales sin embargo tanto
la oms como la agencia europea del
medicamento aseguran que no hay indicios
de que esa causa sea por la vacunación
la solución de astrazéneca fue una de
las primeras y más baratas en llegar al
mercado y hasta el 10 de marzo la
agencia europea reportó que habían
encontrado 30 casos de coagulación
sanguínea entre cerca de 5 millones de
personas vacunadas